sunscreen sticks can be really useful
but how are you meant to use them I did
some experiments to find out and I was
pretty shocked by the results I'm
Michelle of loudmouth and Beauty size
chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist and
sunscreen connoisseur I talk a lot about
sunscreens but I haven't talked that
much about sunscreen sticks these have
been getting more popular and if you've
used any of the newer ones you'll know
there's been a lot of progress since the
thick bright zinc sticks from school
carnivals there are a lot of upsized to
Sticks first off sunscreen sticks are
really convenient you don't need to wash
your hands if you want to reapply you
don't end up with sunscreen all over
your hands you just take off the cap and
glide it onto your skin they're solid so
there's no chance of squirting it
everywhere and you don't need to worry
about liquid limits for planes they're
also really good to use on Wrigley kids
sticks can also be great for reapplying
sunscreen over makeup without smearing
it around too much if you find one that
Glides on smoothly and these days a lot
of them do glide on really smoothly they
can also help with icing sticks are a
lot waxier than lotion so if you have
issues with sunscreen running into your
eyes and stinging then sticks might help
you out and you can use it just around
your eye area but sticks also have a lot
of downsides the most obvious one is it
is a lot harder to measure out how much
you need to use or work out how much
you've applied you need two milligrams
of sunscreen per square centimeter of
skin to get the label protection which
converts to a bit under a quarter
teaspoon for most faces but you can't
really dig out a quarter spoon of a
sunscreen stick without losing a lot of
the advantages of having a stick so I
decided to test how much of each stick I
was applying I tried to Kobo a bib and
Benton six for this video These are
three of the nicest sunscreen sticks
I've tried so far note that these are
all Korean sunscreens they aren't
approved as sunscreens in a lot of
countries including Australia and the US
SPF tests are done by weight so I also
did this by weight to be more accurate a
while ago I measured my face and it
turns out out I need 0.76 grams of
sunscreen to get the labeled SPF for
every stick I zeroed the scales then I
applied what I thought was a very
generous layer more than I would
normally apply the jacobo and a bib
sticks are chemical sunscreens so as
you'd expect there wasn't any white cast
bent and stick is mineral based on
titanium dioxide and it is pretty
non-whitening for a mineral sunscreen
after that very generous layer I
re-weighed the sticks and it turns out I
only applied about one third of the
amount I needed for every stick for an
SPF 50 sunscreen this would translate to
very roughly SPF 19. I also checked how
much time I spent with each stick
actually touching my skin so you can get
an idea of what I considered a generous
application these are about 20 shorter
than the total application time
including the gaps when the stick left
my skin the full procedures I used are
linked in the description out of these I
applied the most of the Benton stick and
I think it's because it is a bit
grippier it didn't Glide as smoothly
over my skin so it took longer before it
felt like I'd covered my skin thoroughly
the jacobo was in the middle and the
abib ended up with the least amount
applied all three of these still felt
really nice on my skin at this stage
jacobo gives more of a matte silky
finish while the ABY feels a bit more
emollient there was only a little white
cast with the Benton onto layer 2 I went
in again for what seemed to me to be
another really generous layer and again
I applied less than I expected this got
me up to an average of SPF 31 which is
good but I can usually apply the full
amount of a lotion sunscreen without
this much effort by this time I spent
one and a half to two and a half minutes
with each sunscreen stick on my skin
after layer 2 the tacopo had caught up
with the Benton and I think that's
because the Benton doesn't grip onto
itself as well as it gripped onto my
skin the textures were still possible
but starting to get slidy I don't think
makeup would stay put too well on top of
this but you might have better luck if
your skin is drier than mine on to layer
3 and this time I got up to average
spf-42 to Kobo 1 but all three were
pretty messy by this point they were
greasy and didn't set the two chemical
sunscreens were still impressively
transparent but I could scrape a white
layer of the Benton off my skin I didn't
even think I could apply any more after
this it was getting to the point where
my skin was applying sunscreen back to
the stick by this stage I had spent an
average of three minutes with each stick
on my skin which is about four minutes
total application time for comparison it
takes me about a minute to apply the
full amount of a lotion on my skin I've
seen a recommendation from the AED for
applying four swipes of a sunscreen
stick to get full protection so I also
tried to count how many slices of each
sunscreen I used I picked four spots on
my face and counted how many times each
stick passed over each spot on average
it was 9 21 and 34 swipes for one two
and three layers four swipes of these
SPF 56 would definitely not be enough
number of swipes and passes also just
seems to be a bad guideline you can see
how I ended up applying a lot more
swipes on my left cheek than my right
even in the aad demonstration video you
can see that her passes aren't
overlapping I also tested applying the
sunscreen sticks on my arms I needed
less about 20 swipes of the jacobo
sunscreen to get full coverage I think
it's because my arm hair grabbed onto
more sunscreen per swipe and I could
press harder and the skin is just a lot
more uniform there's a lot less curves
to move around it was pretty clear 10
swipes wouldn't be enough and four would
definitely not be enough also if you're
wondering you can't see if you've
applied enough sunscreen with a UV
camera everything over Force wipes looks
around the same I'm guessing this could
potentially be the origin of this Force
wise recommendation this also highlights
that UV cameras are a really bad way of
estimating SPF which I've talked about
before in my video on SPF testing So
based on this I really don't think a
sunscreen stick is a great choice as
your main form of sun protection if
you're getting a lot of sun you'll
probably applying a lot less sunscreen
than you think you are I was certainly
surprised and I think some of this is
down to how sticks are formulated
sunscreen lotions are usually about half
water at least and sometimes they also
have volatile solvents like alcohol and
cyclopentasiloxane after applying the
right amount the sunscreen dries down
and these evaporate off your skin there
aren't many volatile ingredients in
sticks everything sits on top of your
skin plus the texture is thicker the
oils don't sink in as much and you can
feel it a lot more if you apply the
right amount of a stick you end up with
a much thicker layer on your skin than
with a lotion it also takes a lot longer
to apply the full amount I also found
that it was easier for me to miss spots
with a stick I checked what the coverage
was like after my first generous layer
which I thought was enough for the
chemical sunscreens using a UV camera
you can't really see mineral sunscreens
very clearly through UV I can apply a
lotion on my face without looking and
only miss a couple of spots but even
while stir up myself I missed a whole
bunch of spots that I've never missed
before like the middle of my nose I also
missed some spots that I missed quite
often like under my eyebrows and next to
my nostrils I don't know what that
spot's called the nose crevice this was
pretty easy to fix you just have to rub
the stick in but again you lose a bit of
that convenience and if you don't have a
UV camera you can't really see which
bits need rubbing you have to rub all
over you can sort of see a bit from the
shine but that white cast from the
mineral stick could actually be handy
here I think the shape of the stick can
make a difference when it comes to
missing spots sticks do come in a lot of
different shapes and I'm not really sure
which one I preferred the curve of the
above stick kind of feels like a face
massage and the y-shape covers the
cheeks and your forehead really quickly
but it is a bit fiddly to get into
awkward areas I think that's also why I
needed less wipes on my arm compared to
my face one slide covers more surface
area on a flat surface than a curved one
so to summer for sunscreen sticks it's
great if you need a small top up
especially over makeup if you want to
avoid getting sunscreen on your hands to
avoid icing and when other options don't
work like if you've got really wriggly
or fussy kids but I wouldn't recommend
them on your own if you need a lot of
sun protection I would recommend a
lotion instead I hope you enjoyed this
deep dive into some of the different
types of sunscreens also check out my
skincare science playlist if you want
more deep Dives